[Music]
pearl skin studio is back to show us how
to keep our skin glowing in this dry
heat so let's welcome studio owner and
master esthetician katya an esthetician
and also our lovely model yes christian
really jealous of christian right now
okay so we're talking how to keep the
skin glowing obviously that means
moisture hydration and i've seen some
amazing before and after photos for
peels yeah now how does that help the
glow yeah chemical peels help help to
brighten up your complexion it's great
for pigmentation great for elasticity it
softens fine lines firms and tightens
this particular peel
is applied on the skin and you're
currently dripping dripping not not
injecting anything guys see it's liquid
this is a brand new peel
and it's from italy
so
why is it different yeah it can be done
all season around okay it's for every
skin color wonderful it's for every skin
type and condition and the best part
it's pretty strong but you don't feel it
you don't look red from it
you don't peel from it so
there's no down time at all okay if you
like a working woman like you and need
to look great all the time you can't
right that's i've always avoided
chemical peels because i knew i was i
wouldn't be able to get on tv the next
day but this is good to know so as you
can see he's not in pain right and we're
seeing some before and afters wow that's
incredible
and the best part also not only you
getting chemical peels
you get massage with it because the
liquid as you can see guys have to be
massaged in it's almost like a getting
deep tissue massage on the face wow
this is amazing i'm so jealous christian
how you doing down there see
nothing pain not red right nothing no
and it's also 100 safe because a lot of
people think yeah chemical people no no
it is safe um the only country
indications are pregnancy right uh
lactating women and active acne and
that's it and how many services do you
recommend for the full effect for the
foreign takes four to six treatments
they have to be booked once a week and
you have to pre-treat your skin
and we also giving you post treatment
and those two products can be
pre-treatment and post treatment and
they receive it for free wow and look at
those hand photos this is amazing and
speaking of the of the products you do
have a special event coming up that the
community is invited to so listen up yes
september 15th we have only eight spots
left the rest is already booked so we're
gonna introduce people to this uh
fabulous peel which is prxt-33 from
italy and it is eighty dollars for the
event instead of 250.
so hurry up guys because it's only eight
spots left visit proskinstudio.com call
us the number is there okay and we'll
see you there wow thank you so much and
christian you are flawless and glowing i
love it thank you so much katya thanks
bye i'm getting in line after you
christian thank you pearlskin studio for
sponsoring this segment if you're ready
for the glow-up call 702-525-5555
or visit
pearlskinstudio.com and we will be right
back